ce jeudi matin les transports en commun
tournaient au ralenti dans les ivelines
en raison des conditions météorologiques
à Oudan en pleine heure de pointe de
nombreux ivelinois étaient bloqués à la
gare faute de train les lignes N et U
étaient à l'arrêt jusqu'à 13h avant une
reprise progressive j'ai appris qu'il
n'y avait pas de train en regardant sur
City mer pas fait attention je pensais
que ça aussi catastrophique et bah du
coup je vais arriver 1 he3etard au
travail direction la maison pas d'autre
solution j'estime de rentrer à la maison
c'est une journée perdue même pagaille
pour les lignes l J et le
rerc c'était aussi compliqué côté bus de
nombreuses lignes étaient fortement
perturbées notamment sur le réseau
grandvailles à midi la situation n'était
toujours pas revenue à la normale à la
gare de 50 an en iveline depuis 6h du
matin je suis là on nous a dit que il y
aura des trains à partir de 10h je suis
rentrée je suis revenue à 10h on nous
dit que ça sera pour midi bon je suis là
pour me dire en temps de voir parce que
il y a rien il y a rien du tout c'est
galère on a dû prendre un uber euh pour
arriver jusqu'ici sur les principaux
axes routiers les chutes de neige ont
été anticipées contrairement à la
semaine dernière les routes étaient
dégagées et sur la 12 et la 13 les poids
lourds n'ont pas eu le droit de circuler
jusqu'à 10h la circulation était en
revanche plus compliquée sur les réseaux
secondaires on traite en priorité les
axes les axes principaux euh donc sur le
réseau secondaire il y a des endroits où
effectivement euh la géographie les
routes sont structurellement en tentees
et donc elles seront elles sont
difficiles à traiter même en journée
donc il faud évidemment être prudent ce
soir pour ceux qui rentrent sur C
secteur moins urbanisé des ivelines
depuis 10h ce jeudi la vigilance orange
est levée dans les ivelines la nuit
prochaine aucune chute de neige n'est
prévue mais la prudence reste de mise
car il va continuer à faire très froid
si vous souhaitez rester informé sur les
interventions des sleuses
l'agglomération de sa-quentin en
evveline a mis en place un service
hivernal service SMS y